Following your passion keeps people
poor, or at least poorer than they ought
to be. And maybe you feel lost right
now. I get it. I've been there. I was
dead broke in my early 20s and I read
all the self-help books I could get my
hands on. And a lot of them said follow
your passion. And ironically, that
didn't help me. Then I started changing
what I did and my life changed as a
result. So problem number one with
follow your passion, it gets cause and
effect backwards. So often we become
passionate about things after we get
good at them, not before. You will hear
people say, "Follow your passion."
You'll hear really smart people, very
successful people say that. And think
about why they might say that. They're
like, "Well, let me look at myself. I'm
passionate about what I do, so just do
what I do. Be passionate." But the thing
is is it's just like saying, "Hey, if
you want to be rich, fly private, or if
you want to be tall, go play
basketball." It doesn't work that way.
You get rich and then as a result of
being rich, you can fly private. It's
not that flying private is the reason
that you're rich, right? So you will do
the work to become passionate. Not that
being passion is necessarily the thing.
Now here's the thing. Some people are
like, well, some people just naturally
have a passion. No, they found the thing
earlier. They had their chance
experience when they were in their early
toddler years or they're five, six,
seven. They start painting and it's
like, oh god. So they follow the same
process. They had some sort of chance
encounter. They start doing a little bit
of deliberate practice. All of a sudden
they realize there's value in their
skill. Their parents, their friends are
like, oh, you're good at drawing. Oh,
you must really like this. And then
boom, all of a sudden deeper passion
emerges. They start identifying as it
and then boom, competence, skill, and
then passion. And so I say this to say
that some of you, myself included, like
never really had some thing that just
magically occurred. Uh you have to start
stuff that you're not necessarily as
good at and have broader exposure to the
allowed chance to take root. Number two,
it's too vague and assumes everyone has
a clear passion. And many people have no
idea, right? So, it's hard to say that
you like X more than Y. You might like
both, right? And so, it's very hard to
quantify. It makes it hard to decide.
And so, how good you are at something is
a little bit easier to make an AB
decision on, right? So, if I said, you
know, do you like pizza more than you
like tacos? You might be like, I don't
know. Like, I kind of like both of them,
right? But if I said, are you better at
English than you are at math? It's
probably easier for you to make a call
there, right? And so preferences versus
skills are easier to determine a
decision path which then gives you
clarity on what next steps to take. So
even examples. So Bill Gates tried a
bunch of different things. So he tried
law, he tried mathematics, he tried
programming before he found his
direction and he wasn't following a
clear passion, but he was exploring his
abilities and opportunities. And I'll
give you a personal example. Back in the
day before I started business, I was
like, well, I kind of like fro yo. And I
learned a little bit about that. I was
like, I like fitness and I like test
prep. And so I kind of had these
different skill sets and these different
domains, but I was only able to have
clarity once I started and then took
action on it because then the feedback
loop begins. And so the objective of
developing passion is to get a feedback
loop started. So three, liking something
doesn't make you good at it. All right?
So think about it like this. Being
passionate doesn't even guarantee that
you have the skills for it. And
sometimes it's better to have a career
and enjoy your passions in your free
time. My dad used to tell me, "Well, if
I did what I was passionate about, I'd
be a bartender at a ski slope." And I
mean, he used to say it in Jess, but
like the point rang clear to me. He was
like, "Listen, there's things that you
do to provide for your family. There's
things you do to provide for yourself,
build a future, have security, and
there's things that you do uh with your
free time." Now, some people are like,
"Those things can be one and the same."
But I'll tell you what, my dad loves
what he does. And I'll tell you that he
didn't start it because he loved it. He
started because he wanted to just be a
productive member of society. Maybe it's
a little bit that immigrant in me, but
like you know the rest of the world
isn't so comfortable that they're
sitting in sunshine and rainbows. But
here's the crazy part. Many of them are
more fulfilled than we are because they
don't see anything wrong with doing the
work. Doing the work is seen as a very
like it's seen as a beautiful
responsibility. Seen as a good thing.
Guy provides for his family. Nothing
wrong with that. So I'll give you a
little a little example here. So Warren
Buffett follows a philosophy that he
calls the circle of competence. All
right? Which is focusing not on what
excites you but on what you understand
best. and his passion follows his
competence, not the other way around.
So, for example, me personally, all the
gym owners I know love fitness, but many
of them were very broke. And so, they
said, hey, I should start a business
around fitness because I'm passionate
about it. And then made no money because
they had to realize, oh, wait, I don't
know anything about business. And so,
it's like being understanding fitness is
like 5% of the fitness business. It's
just kind of like, oh, I like cooking. I
should start a restaurant. It's like,
well, it's about 5%. And what's crazy is
the thing that you're actually
passionate about, cooking or doing
fitness, has almost nothing to do with
monetizing that skill. Real. So here's
the fourth reason I think it's bad
advice. Follow your passion skips the
hard work part. So getting really good
at something means practicing the boring
or the hard parts too, right? So for
example, I actually really like playing
ping pong, something that I enjoy. So I
decided I was like, "Oh, I'm going to
look into what it would take to get
better at ping pong because I do like it
and I play it a lot when I can." And I
started watching what some of the teams
do and they're like, "All right, 500
forehands, 500 backhands in a row." And
I was like, "Oh, yeah. I don't want to
do this." And so I may be passionate
about it, but I don't want to do the
work that is required to go from
passionate to like world class or state
level or whatever, right? All of the
research on deliberate practice shows
that it's not an enjoyable process. I
want to say this again. all the research
on deliberate practice which is required
for competence and competence is
certainly required for making money in
whatever career you want is that it is
not an enjoyable process. This is what
the research showed. All right, I was
actually kind of blown away by that. And
so when you're repeating the same sales
script over and over again, it's not
that fun. All right, it's very tedious.
Or you do the same basketball shot over
and over again, right? Or you know, you
do the same presentation, the same
speech, you do it over and over and over
again. So it's not novel. It's just
focused on tiny iterations on feedback
loops. is just sanding off the edges
over and over and over again. And once
all of the first level of roughness uh
is faded off, you take a a lower grade
uh sandpaper and then all of a sudden
you do it another level of smoothness.
Like you just you approach it in levels
of feedback. I mean, one of my favorite
quotes from myself is the real work
begins when the excitement to work ends.
A lot of skill development is like
running a marathon where you have a
couple people might cheer you on in the
beginning for making a decision to start
and then for 26.1 miles basically no one
cares. You're running and you're like,
"Wow, this is really long." And then
you're like, "Oh my god, I have to do
four more of these 15s, right?" And
you're like, "Holy God, this is or five
more of these 1/5s is tough." And then
at the very end, right as you're about
to accomplish, people just see you
sprint the last bit and they're like,
"Oh, congratulations." But you're like,
"It's the mundane middle. You have to
master the middle. That's where all the
That's where all the gains come in. So,
I'll share a rule that has worked very
well for me for developing skills. And
so, this is the $100 million leads book.
Step four of Outbound, I talked about
this, which is reach out to them 100 per
day, right? And so, I call this the rule
of 100. I talk about it at length a
little further in the book, but like
when I did my book launch, actually for
this book two years ago, I practiced the
presentation that I did 90 times before
I actually did it live. Right? Now, the
rule of 100 is about doing a h 100red
per day, right? So, it's hard for me to
do the entire preparation 100 times a
day because there's literally not that
much that many hours. But, I did it
three full times per day. It was a
90-minute presentation. So, about four
and a half hours of deliberate practice
per day. And I would watch the recording
and then I would tweak the presentation
where I stumbled or I felt like I needed
a better visual, whatever. And I did
that every single day. And so, the idea
is that it just requires significantly
more work. And it's also not going to be
fun. And the more practice you have at
practicing, the better you get at it.
Because I know that practice precedes
excellence. And so the more times you
start practicing and realizing that that
practice leads to winning, you start to
get excited to practice, not for that
practice itself, but because what
practice means to you because you know
what comes after practice, which is
winning. Here's the fifth reason that I
think following your passion is terrible
advice. It also sets false expectations.
So, it makes you feel like work should
always be fun and exciting and it isn't.
An early mentor of mine told me and I
will never forget this. He said, "Never
try to make money out of something you
love." He said, "Because then you'll
just ruin it and turn it into work." And
it was so interesting because he was a
very successful guy. And of course,
you're going to have people on both
sides of this. And again, I I want to be
clear. I think that you want to do
things you enjoy. I just think that it
takes time of not enjoying it to get to
the part where you enjoy it because it
takes time to get good. And so for
anybody who's going to like try and blow
me up on this, by all means do it. We're
all going to die and no one's going to
remember us. But like the point is you
have to develop passion rather than
follow it. You have to create it. And so
I'll give you a different example. Many
Hollywood actors realize that it sucks
and that many acting careers involve
more waiting, rejection, and business
administration than actually creative
fulfillment. And so Jeff Bezos talks
about this where he says everything is
overhead. And so there's like you might
have you basically have like maybe 10%
or 20% or 30% of your day. Like if you
have 30% of your day that you love. I
feel like you're winning at life, right?
Because the other 70% is stuff that is
required in order to get that 30%.
Because the thing is is let's look at
the alternative. You could just do
nothing, right? And I think that if you
do nothing or you hate everything you do
that there's probably a middle path. And
I'll also say something that I think
most people will disagree with, but I'll
just shoot I'm going to shoot my shot. I
think that the way that you approach the
work you do can fundamentally change the
work itself. And so there's this great
um I think it's a parable or analogy,
maybe it's a story. Um but basically of
this man who uh basically swept floors
for like 35 years and he just did an
amazing job. It's a Japanese uh story
and the way that he approached this and
was like how are you like there's no way
that this is fun or interesting.
And he ends up saying like, I imagine
that they're paying me a million dollars
every single day to sweep the floors.
And so I think, how would I sweep them
if they paid me a million dollars every
day to sweep? And so it changed his
entire perception of
how to approach the work. And if the
work that you do, um, I saw this this
this little post that went viral the
other day of a waiter that had a tip
that said, "Do better," right? So
instead of having money there, it said
basically $0. And the person said do
better. And he said, "Normally, you
know, I could, you know, take this and
be like really offended or say these
people sucked." But he decided to take
it to heart. And so the next day he
showed up to work and was like, "I'm
just going to try and be the best." He's
like, "I'm going to try and remember
everyone's names. I'm going to try and
smile, be charismatic." He's like, "And
the craziest thing happened. All of a
sudden people were telling me I was so
nice and they started giving me bigger
tips and they started talking to me
about other opportunities." And the
thing is is that he was still doing the
same job but he was the way he
approached it was different. And so like
would you say that you're was he did he
become passionate about his work or he
did he just decide to see the larger
picture that the work we do works on us
more than we work on it? And so that
leads me naturally to the sixth reason
that I think follow your passion is
terrible advice. Um it also just ignores
money realities. Right? Just because you
love something doesn't mean you can make
enough money doing it. So just look at
American Idol triyouts, right? Ain't
nobody trying to see them sing, right?
Even though those people love it. And so
I remember for me early in my career, I
wasn't driven really by a specific
passion. I just didn't really want to be
broke anymore. Like as terrible as this
sounds, like people used to ask me like,
"What's the mission of Gym Launch?" The
mission of Gym Launch when I started Gym
Launch was Alex not being broke. That
was the mission of Gym Launch. Now
here's the thing. As I developed the
business, it did become to take an
industry from its knees to its feet. But
at the moment when I started gym lunch,
I just lost everything for the second
time. And I was like, I I am not doing
this again. I was like, this has to
work, right? And so I I say this that
like a lot of people have a lot of
romanticism, but it's just not based in
reality. And people doctor their
memories. They look back and it feels
different than when you're going through
it. And I'll give you a simple example
of this. when you look back on some of
the hardest things you've gone through,
you probably have a sense of pride for
having gotten through them, but you're
proud in retrospect. And so if someone
says, "Hey, you know what's it like?"
It's like, "Oh, you know what? You got
to you just got to enjoy the moment. You
got to revel in it." It's like you're
not reing in it. It sucks. But you keep
going. You persist because of what you
know it's building inside of you, the
skill sets so that you can persevere at
a higher level. So I'll give you I'll
give you a business example. All right?
So there's a very harsh reality of
supply and demand. All right? And so if
your passion is something that a lot of
people like to do, there's probably a
lot of people wanting to do it. And so
that means there's a lot of supply. And
so it's going to be super super
competitive. Think acting, think
singing, think painting. And so it might
not be the most realistic path for
making money. And like one of my early
mentors said, it's like, well, what
stops you from just painting when you
want to paint and then making money when
you want to make money. Seventh reason I
think that follow your advice is follow
your advice. Follow your advice is bad
advice is bad passion. Follow your
passion is bad advice. All right is that
it misses often more important life
things. All right. So good work needs
decent pay, good co-workers, good
recognition, security and purpose. All
right? And so the environment you work
in will absolutely affect how much you
like it and how long you can endure it.
All right? So this is a a quote from my
good friend Shiron Servata. Um, in my
20s I thought it was about the
destination. In my 30s I thought it was
about the journey. And in my 40s I
realized it's about the company. And I
thought that was so profound. It's like
in the beginning you're just you're
always like, "How do I get there? How do
I get there? How do I get there?" And
then little later you're like, you know
what? It's about enjoying the process.
But then later you're like, well, how do
I enjoy the process? Well, if I've got
the people I like around me, it makes
almost any process enjoyable. And so
there's other components that factor
into the overall soup of what you want
to do in your life and what you actually
spend your time on. And so I'll give you
two examples. So imagine uh you've got
one career where you do what you like,
but it's terrible work environments. You
hate all the people. You actually don't
like the the the thing you're producing,
but you like the work that you do, but
not what the outcome is. Right? So it's
removing purpose. Um and it doesn't
allow you to do some of the other things
that you enjoy. Well, that would
probably be pretty painful. On the flip
side, if you had a job where you're
like, "Okay, I don't like this component
of my job, but I like literally
everything else." Well, you'd probably
have a more filling life that way. Now,
I will zoom out for a moment if we want
to break the world for a
second. You don't need to have a
fulfilling life. Who made that demand of
the
universe? Anyways,
uh so I'll give you some people like,
well, life should be life should be
fulfilling. I should it life should make
me happy, right? You just demand of the
universe. And by doing that, by the way,
you create space between you and the
outcome, which means you'll never
achieve it. Anyways, so eighth reason
why follow your passion is terrible
advice is that it doesn't allow
flexibility and a changing world. This
is a big one. All right? And a changing
you. So think about like this. What did
you like when you were 12?
probably different things than you like
when you're 22, which I can promise you
is different than the things that you
like at 32 and probably different than
things that you like at 52. And so the
thing is is that the world cares also
about different things 20 years later.
And so you are going to change and the
world is going to change about what you
like and about what it likes. And so if
you say follow your passion, what if you
change or the world change as that's
happening? And so being obsessed with
your one thing doesn't give you the
flexibility to evolve. And so for
example, what if you were really
passionate about making MySpace pages
that was something you're really
passionate about. Well, the world moved
on. And so like either you're going to
move on or the world moves on. And if
you always obsess about that one thing,
then it's like that might change. And if
you if you burn all these boats around
this one passion, it assumes that it
will be there forever. And that's not
reality. And here's the ninth reason
that I think follow your passion is
terrible advice. It's self-focused
rather than others focused. And there's
tons of research that says that people
who focus on others are the happiest if
that's your goal. You might not want to
be the happiest. So fine. And so we tend
to look back and are proud of the hard
things that we overcame, especially in
service of other people or a larger
mission. So for me, I would make real
business education accessible for
everyone. And the thing is is that I
don't always want to record content. I
don't always want to think about what
we're going to talk about today or what,
you know, what we're going to put out.
But the the service of that mission is
very valuable for me. And there's a
different body of research. I can't tell
you where it is. So you can choose to
believe it or not. But that people can
actually endure a significantly larger
amount of pain for other people. So hear
me out. So if if if you got hooked up to
an electric shock machine and they said,
"Cool, we're just going to turn this up
and just tell us when to stop." People
stop. But if you tell the person that
their loved one is in the other room and
that every shock that you take, they
don't have to take, people's tolerance
for pain goes up like tenfold. And so to
me, I see that as an allegory for how we
can choose to live our lives. So that
person who's experiencing the pain for
let's say their loved one, their wife,
their spouse, their daughter, their
their their son, do you think that in
that moment when they're when they feel
like they're shielding the storm from
the people they love that they don't
feel like they have purpose, but
objectively they're suffering? See how
there's layers to this? And so the idea
is I think that saying follow your
passion is very self-interested. It
actually doesn't allow you to plug into
a much stronger motivation or fuel. And
so I would prefer follow your purpose.
It's called the martyrdom effect. But
basically you can handle way more pain
in the service of others which is wild.
But the thing is is if you're like man
I'm struggling to get motivated. It's
because it's you're trying to get
motivated for you rather than get
motivated for other people. And I know
that sounds a little fufu but at the end
of the day like the research is the
research right? Like we are built this
way. We're social creatures. And it
would make sense that people get
applauded for sheltering and protecting
and serving the community. And I think
that that's so woven into our culture or
most cultures that we're willing to do
so much for it. I can tell you right
now, I absolutely can take more pain for
Leila than I can for it and just replace
Ila with whatever that thing is that you
love. And so I want to I want to tell
you this story cuz I think it's uh it's
a parable that really resonates deeply
with me and it's similar to that
Japanese man who who sweeps the floors,
which is a traveler came upon three
stone cutters working at a quarry. And
so he asks them what they were doing.
The first stone cutter replies, "I'm
cutting stone. I'm exhausted. It's
backbreaking work. I'm miserable." This
He goes to the second stone cutter. He
says, "You know, what are you doing
here?" He says, "Uh, I'm earning a
living to support my family." And, you
know, cool. He goes to the third stone
cutter and he says, "What are you
doing?"
The third stone cutter smiles and he
says, "I'm building a cathedral that's
going to inspire people for generations
that my grandchildren and their
grandchildren are going to be able to go
to and worship our Lord." And the thing
is is that all three stone cutters, all
three men are doing the same work
fundamentally having an entirely
different experience of what that work
means to them. And so that same work
that you do that right now might feel
terrible can be a job. That work can be
a career or that work can be a
calling simply depending on your own
perspective. And so maybe just do what
the world wants that you're good at it
and then allow yourself the time to
become passionate about it along the way
as you get better. And so passion
happens as a consequence, not a
requirement. So if you're like that's
all well and good, Alex, but what do I
do? Well, big operationalization fan.
And so what do you do instead of
following your passion? So here's a
practical actionoriented framework that
will invert that advice into positive
steps that anyone can take. Number one,
start with curiosity, not passion. So
begin by exploring things that pique
your interest, even mildly. All right?
Just like Duckworth research showed,
most successful people didn't start with
a burning passion. They began with just
simple curiosity that they were willing
to investigate. They were willing to
follow up. A different way of saying
that is just something that you might be
interested in, right? The second is
embrace the learning process. So commit
to developing the skills and competence
first. Get good first. Recognize that
mastery precedes passion. Getting good
precedes enjoying it, not the other way
around. And set
skillspecific building goals rather than
kind of waiting for motivation to strike
because I promise you, you're going to
wait for a long time. Number three,
value your existing abilities. So assess
what you're already good at and then
consider building from there. Like
Warren Buffett says, look at the circle
of competence, right? Focus on the areas
of natural advantages. Some things you
naturally have done more early on in
your life. Just do more of those things.
Four, commit to the deliberate process.
Burn the boats. And I define commitment
as the elimination of alternatives.
Meaning accept that meaningful progress
requires hard work and fundamentals
might not feel exciting, right? Like
Olympic athletes do so many repetitive
drills. Like uh Phelps used to talk
about just eight hours of swimming. Can
you imagine that? Just lap after lap
after lap after lap after lap after lap.
It's just so many repetitions. And just
understand that excellence requires
practice and the boring parts are
included. Five, set realistic
expectations. So recognize that all work
involves tedious aspects, stuff that
sucks, right? So instead of expecting
constant enjoyment, aim for overall
satisfaction and meaning. And just
remember that even dream jobs like Baso
said have administrative tasks
challenges. They have overhead, right?
They have stuff that sucks. It's just
part of life. Six, take the reality of
money seriously, right? Like money will
not bring you happiness, but it can help
you avoid pain. Now, I also have a
little bit of a a nuggie on this, which
is that people do get happier up to a
certain amount of money and then it
stops. Alex's theory on this. Spending
money is a skill. Most people can only
learn how to spend money up to here and
then they don't learn how to spend it
effectively. I believe that money can
continue to make you happier as you
develop the skill of spending in a way
that gets you better returns on in on
intangible returns rather than tangible
returns. So if you have the if you have
to pick between two different things,
follow the path that might have higher
income earning. If you're about even on
both, follow the money. Next, prioritize
other environmental factors. All right?
So if you want to change your life,
change your environment. I've said this
a hundred times, but if you want, if
you're like, I'm really getting I'm
struggling to do to do this, you know,
to find this passion, go to a place
where other people are passionate about
it. All right? That environment in of
itself will create multiple feedback
loops because all we're really looking
for here, guys, like just be very real
is you just want to find a feedback
loop. That's all we're looking for. You
just find want to find a place where you
can do something and get someone that
says that sucked. That was terrible.
This is what you need to do better or
different. And so finding a place where
you have supportive colleagues or you've
got supportive people who are all kind
of in pursuit of the same thing, all
trying to get better. That's the the
like it will change your life. Next,
allow your passions to evolve. So stay
open to developing new interests
throughout your life. You don't have to
be stuck with one thing. And if you
change your mind, that's okay, right?
Your 40-year-old self will likely have
different passions than your 20-year-old
self. They probably will find different
people interesting at 40 as you do as
20, right? And the world will also
change, too. So having that flexibility
is important. And so committing to this
one passion forever, it's it's it's too
heavy of a decision, I think. And so if
you come into it saying this might
change will allow you to take the first
step because it's not this has to be the
perfect pick. I have to this has to be
the one thing forever. It's like it's
too big, right? Just shrink it down like
all right well I'm kind of interested in
this for now. So start, right? And then
finally connect your work to serving
others. And I think this is arguably one
of the biggest ones just because there's
so much research that supports it is
that you just want to find ways on how
your work benefits other people. You
look at think about the stone cutters,
right? All three guys are doing the same
work. One of them feels like so
incredibly passionate about this because
it's helping the world. It's helping his
family out and he's getting paid while
he does it. Like and the crazy part is
that all of them are doing the same
work. And so I think the easiest way to
become passionate about what you do is
to choose to become passionate about
what you do and find a reason that's
larger than yourself to pursue it. And
that passion and your ability to
withstand the pain because the pain now
has purpose behind it rather than it
being meaningless. And if you want to
see a real person taking their passion
and then turning it into uh you know a
monetized business, I did this full
breakdown of a girl who's really into
fashion and stylist stuff. Don't worry,
you don't have to be into that.